hey everyone i am back for another
episode uh today we're going to be
starting to cover transactions and then
from there i'll probably do be doing um
something like a database comparison so
first of all just quickly um if you guys
are watching this can you go in the
comments section and let me know if you
mind that i'm using a webcam like i have
a high quality camera from um you know
my only fan stays which you can check
out at onlyfans.comcop
but um yeah i'm just kind of curious if
the webcam is sufficient because i feel
like my microphone's pretty good and i'm
you know it doesn't really matter what i
look like i just look uglier in high
definition so
you know i feel like this is fine but uh
yeah anyways let's start talking about
transactions um
i hope this video is useful and i'm
probably going to break this into two
parts so i can cover weak isolation
levels next all right enjoy
okay so let's talk about transactions
well what are they transactions are a
database abstraction that bundle a bunch
of operations to the database so reads
and writes into one basically package of
operations that either all succeed or
they all fail
the entire point of transactions is to
implement this guarantee called acid
where acid stands for atomicity
consistency isolation and durability so
i'll explain what that means in the next
slide so atomicity is basically saying
this let's say we have a bunch of reads
and writes it's never going to be the
case that say some of the rights are
going to work and some of the rights are
going to fail and then the rights that
worked are going to lead aside leave a
side effect on the database it's going
to be the case that it is one atomic
unit of a transaction meaning that
there's never going to be a case where
only half the transaction works and half
doesn't it's either all going to be
committed or it's all going to be
aborted
as far as consistency goes this is
basically just saying that the database
is going to do what it's supposed to
if a transaction works it's going to
stay that way it's not going to be
partially complete or anything and as a
result you can expect that your
invariants about the data are going to
hold even in the face of faults if there
is a fault the transaction is just going
to get aborted and there's not going to
be any side effects so all is well
the next one which we're going to be
discussing a lot more in detail is
isolation isolation means that
concurrently executing transactions can
act as if they're the only one currently
performing an operation on the data we
don't have to worry about race
conditions we don't have to worry about
interleaved transactions and we don't
have to worry about anything like lost
updates
isolation is kind of the main reason
that transactions take a big performance
penalty on the database and we'll
discuss that in depth a little bit more
finally there's durability once a
transaction is complete it's on the disk
i mean in theory sure if i came along
with a hammer and broke the disk it's
not durable but you can only make so
many guarantees and the point is you
know it's durable to the extent that the
hard drive it's written on is terrible
okay so now how are we going to actually
implement isolation because like i said
isolation is kind of the toughest part
it's basically saying there can be a
bunch of concurrent threads operating on
a database and we're not going to have
any concurrency bugs
isolation insinuates that you don't have
to worry about the um you know like the
actual ordering of each right in the
transaction
amongst two transactions we just know
that it's going to work so first let's
talk about actual serial execution which
is the simplest way to implement this
actual serial execution is saying this
we're only going to actually have one
thread running on a database
it means that all of those queries are
going to be run on a single cpu core and
it's only possible under the following
conditions
a all of the data in the database is
stored in memory why is this the case
well if you had to keep making all of
these disk reads and disk writes those
take too long so the only way that we
can actually get the throughput that we
need on a single cpu core is if all the
data is in memory there are some pretty
popular in-memory databases like redis
and memcached and as a result using
things like that we could maybe make
this actually work
another thing is that you have to use
stored procedures typically what you
would do when using a transaction is go
ahead and actually pass the database you
know something like sql instructions
over the network
however just by virtue of even passing
those instructions over the network
we're wasting a lot of time that we need
the cpu to be doing operations so
instead what we actually do is store the
transaction in advance on the database
as something called a stored procedure
and then you would end up calling that
stored procedure there are a few issues
with this one is that it implies that
you already know in advance what
transactions you're going to be doing
and secondly and possibly even more
importantly is that stored procedures
are kind of an afterthought by databases
they're hard to version control and for
the most part a lot of databases don't
use a popular language in order to write
stored procedures which make them pretty
annoying as developers to work with
finally
and this is kind of
more of an optional thing but it would
help a lot is you want to keep all the
transactions limited to one partition
if you have multiple partitions involved
in a transaction you're going to have to
be dealing with network calls and the
thought of having only one cpu core to
deal with things that are going to be
waiting on a network means that other
transactions that have to be
run by the core afterwards are going to
be delayed significantly that's
obviously a very big problem
so in general the pros of this are that
it's very simple to implement
and it's good because generally speaking
unless you're doing huge analytic
queries on the database those
transactions are probably going to be
pretty short however the con is that
most operations are not necessarily most
but a good chunk of you know hugely
scaled out applications can't actually
just run all of their transactions on a
single cpu core and also like i said we
have to deal with stored procedures
okay now let's talk about the far more
popular solution that's implemented in
most databases called two-phase locking
so if you don't know what a lock is
basically it's this you can put it on an
object and
if you have multiple concurrent threads
so multiple threads running in parallel
trying to grab the lock once one thread
is holding the lock the other thread may
not and it may not operate on that
object however two-phase locking changes
those locks a little bit in the sense
that now instead of just having a lock
which is either held or not held and
only one process can have it at a time
the lock now has two different modes
shared mode or exclusive mode in shared
mode you can have a bunch of processes
or transactions that want to read that
object however in exclusive mode
you need this to write and in exclusive
mode no other processes can be holding
that lock
so the point is that multiple
transactions can read from a row if
they're holding a lock in shared mode
but the second that they want to write
to that row they have to upgrade that
lock to exclusive mode additionally if
they're currently holding the lock in
shared mode and another process is
holding the lock in shared mode they're
not going to be able to upgrade to
exclusive mode you can only go to
exclusive mode once there are no other
processes holding that lock at all so
before i actually get into my
demonstration of how that would work i
should also mention a pretty significant
edge case of two-phase locking known as
predicate locks so let's imagine that we
want to run a transaction to book a
meeting room and we know that in order
to book this meeting room first we want
to read from the database and say find
me all of the rows that are
you know for this meeting room for a
given time so we can make sure that no
one has already booked the room
however after we've made that query for
all those bookings another transaction
comes along and actually goes ahead and
writes a new row that takes the booking
that we want
it's impossible that we could stop this
because there's no way that we can put a
lock on a row in the database that
doesn't exist yet however there is a
solution to this known as predicate
locks
predicate locks are basically saying we
are going to put a lock on all objects
that satisfy a query even if they don't
yet exist so in this case let's say i
want to book
i don't know a certain room with a
certain time
i would say to put a predicate lock on
all of those meetings with that room and
that time
so that in the event that another
transaction tries to create a row for
that my predicate lock would already be
holding it and they wouldn't be able to
do so the big issue here is that this
actually performs really poorly you have
to do a huge query basically finding all
the rows in the database that might
apply to the predicate lock and then
additionally every row that's added you
also have to check if it applies to the
predicate lock
so what alternative can we use that's
kind of a little bit of an optimization
on this it's called index range locking
and i'm going to show that off right now
so as you can see imagine i have the
following database table on the left
here and imagine that i have the
following index on the right which shows
me
the meeting room and the corresponding
rows for it so let's say i want to book
the oval office for tuesday as you can
see it's not booked there's only the
oval office for monday and wednesday so
if i wanted to do this i would first
apply a predicate lock to all of the
oval office slots for tuesday
and as you can see that wouldn't apply
to any rows currently however like i
said that's going to be pretty slow
because we'd have to query the entire
database to find all of the places where
the oval office and tuesday comes up
however what if i just went ahead and
instead decided to put a lock on all of
the oval office rows this would be a lot
faster because we already know from our
index that the oval office has primary
ids 2 and 3. so as a result of that i
know that any oval office meeting on
tuesday is going to be on that greater
set including all of the meetings that
include the oval office
as a result of that this predicate lock
is actually going to be much faster
although it does come at the cost of
potentially locking too many things and
slowing down other unrelated
transactions this is known as index
range locking
because we're basically taking a super
set of all the things that we want to
put a predicate lock on however it's
faster because of the fact that we
already have this query pre
pre-populated for us via the index so as
you can see i would then just go ahead
and put a lock on ids two and three even
though neither actually relevant for my
query it's a superset and if there was
an oval office with tuesday meeting in
there it would have locked that too
okay so now let's talk about two phase
lockings performance it's actually
pretty bad why because of the fact that
we end up using so many locks we slow
down a bunch of unrelated transactions
that may not have actually caused a
concurrency bug
additionally we often have two-phase
locking leading to deadlocks and the
database has to detect when there's a
deadlock abort one of those transactions
involved and then let the other complete
what's a deadlock it just means when two
processes are waiting for the resources
of one another and as a result neither
can go forward so i'm gonna show an
example of this right now
let's say i have the key jordan
attractiveness in my database and right
now it's an eight because you know i'm
looking pretty handsome these days but i
could cut a little bit further get this
six-pack popping or whatever
so now i have a transaction one because
i've gone to the gym a little bit more
and got my bench from 225 to 245
and so transaction one is going to read
jordan attractiveness get the value of
that and then increment it by one
so what it's going to do is grab the
shared lock to read and then finally
transaction 2 is now going to come in
because i've you know got my squad up 20
pounds as well and it is also going to
try and read jordan attractiveness and
increment it so right now if you're
familiar with concurrent programming you
know that this could potentially be an
issue in the sense that they would both
read jordan attractiveness both see that
it's eight
both add 1 to it and then the final
value would be 9 as opposed to 10 which
is what it's supposed to be
so anyways after t2 comes along it's
going to read the shared lock or it's
going to grab the shared lock and both
of these transactions see that the value
of jordan attractiveness is 8 which is
bad
finally now we have a deadlock both of
these guys want to write the jordan
attractiveness is 9 but neither can grab
the exclusive block because they're both
holding the shared lock as you can see
this is the definition of a deadlock and
the database is going to go ahead and
have to abort one of these transactions
so let's say it aborts transaction 2.
now we're back to the situation we're in
before where we have the shared lock
grabbed by t1 and t1 is now going to
upgrade itself to the exclusive block
and then increment my attractiveness now
that i'm a 9. now t2 can finally come
along and be retried do the same thing
where it grabs the shared lock
go ahead and upgrade itself to the
exclusive rock uh exclusive lock to take
a right
and then finally now i'm a 10 which is
what i currently am accurate
okay serializable snapshot isolation is
the third possible option for
implementing isolation
so what's the idea well basically we
just let all of the threads run
concurrently like normal and only revert
a transaction if there was a concurrency
bug that's been detected
so all reads are going to be taken from
a snapshot and basically we're looking
for two things let's say that we're
going to read from a snapshot and we see
that an uncommitted write has occurred
before the read so basically we have
another transaction that is going to
write to this object but hasn't yet done
so
in the event that when our transaction
which is just read is going to write
that object we have to check if that
uncommitted right has now been committed
if so we need to abort it it's also
possible the uncommitted right might end
up being aborted which is why we don't
just
abort our read right away by virtue if
they're being an uncommitted right
additionally let's say we read an item
with transaction 1 and in the meantime
right after we do that read transaction
2 both
has an uncommitted write and then it
commits
we can actually keep track of all the
transactions that have read a given item
and as a result the second that a write
changes that item we go ahead and abort
all the transactions that have read it
okay so evaluating the performance of
this it's actually really good and
really promising it's a relatively new
algorithm and so it's not implemented as
heavily in database systems but i think
it's going to start being implemented
more so
the great thing about this is since um
in many applications there aren't tons
of concurrency issues on the data set
it's far faster than two-phase locking
which is very pessimistic and goes ahead
and tries to lock everything possible to
make sure nothing bad can go wrong
on the other hand if there are a ton of
concurrency bugs we're going to be
reverting a ton of transactions in ssi
and as a result of that all these
reverts are going to make this very slow
and perhaps we'd be better off using
two-phase locking
okay so in conclusion transactions are a
really useful abstraction
and it makes using the database very
easy to reason about however at the same
time the main objective of these videos
is to build a highly scalable
application and often times transactions
don't scale well
they are very non-performant as a result
of having to actually implement all of
this isolation and as a result of that
many databases have instead chosen to
use weaker isolation guarantees and we
can cover those next video
in addition as i mentioned there are
three types of isolation implementations
and let's go and summarize them one more
time actual serial execution is super
simple to think about because it doesn't
require locks however the throughput is
limited to one cpu core we have to keep
all of our data in memory which is not
good if there's a ton of it because
memory is more expensive and also we
have to use stored procedures which are
annoying
finally we have two-phase locking and
serializable snapshot isolation
2pl is basically used in most databases
but it seems like it's on its way out
because of ssi 2pl is basically a
pessimistic concurrency control and as a
result of that there's tons of
unnecessary locking and tons of
deadlocks which need to be resolved ssi
on the other hand is more optimistic and
only reverts transactions once they've
actually led to a concurrency bug as a
result of that in most applications
where there aren't tons of concurrency
bugs but you they're more of like an
edge case or an afterthought ssi works
better
all right i hope this one makes a little
bit of sense guys uh i'm gonna do weak
isolation levels for the next video
and then we can go ahead and get to a
database comparison